Let's start by focusing on this positively charged particle.
If it is positively charged particle, we know there are two forces acting on it.
There is this horizontal force pulling it towards the negative charge
and there's this vertical force pulling it along the electric field
and we know that when we add this two vectors together,
we get a net force vector that makes this angle θ1 with the horizontal.
And using our knowledge of trigonometry, we can conclude that the tangent of this angle θ1
must be equal to the force caused by the electric field
divided by the force pulling the positive charge towards the negative charge
and it turns out, I can write a similar equation for the negatively charged particle.
Now I'm going to take this two equations and divide this equation by this equation
and doing that division, I get this equation here.
Now, in order to clean things up a bit here, we need to make one key observation.
We know from Newton's Third Law that when this positive charge
pulls on this negative charge that the negative charge
pulls back on the positive charge with an identical force.
This means that this horizontal forces must be exactly the same.
We can actually cancel out these two forces terms here.
This gives us that the ratio of the tangents between the two angles
is equal to the ratio between the forces the two particles feel from the electric field,
and we can always write the forces the particles feel from our electric field
as just the electric field's strength times the charge on those particles.
And we see here that the electric field strength will cancel
leaving just the ratio of the two charges.
This means that the ratio of the charges on the two particles is exactly equal
to the ratio of the tangents of the angles that the net force vectors make with the horizontal.
That's pretty cool and pointing in my known values for this angles here,
I can calculate the ratio of these two tangents.
In this case, we got the ratio between these two charges is about equal to nine.
If you're able to get this, great work.